monacy was supposed to be the next
simple like I liked this on Twitter and
people were kind of arguing with me
because they think simple flicking super
fast is the same thing what I'm talking
about is him seeing information on the
screen and reacting to it like the first
moment that he starts to adjust like
that's faster than anybody I've seen I
think this guy is a guy that you'd face
him and face it and you'd think oh my
God this kid is a mother effing Chia
there's no way you could be that good
being 16 years of age the young
prodigies Pro Journey started on Navi Jr
and he resembled the goat on the server
and off so much it seemed like a future
playing alongside him as teammates was
The Logical Next Step but modesty
decided to forge his own path and before
long he began to look like the real
future of Counter-Strike the policy is
in a lot of trouble no scopes one of
them it keeps going 10 seconds he fakes
the ball and spins around takes down
Woody and now he said the hug running up
close and personal oh what a flick get
it doesn't have
and there it is one of the best clutches
we've seen But it travels into the site
one on two from Odyssey now it's
sacrificial away what's funny
[Applause]
takes down the goat this is the story of
monessey
[Music]
anyone who's even remotely familiar with
FPS Esports knows who simple is he's a
generational talent and his prowess and
the server is unmatched
that's enough
to get a quick shot onto zote and he'll
continue to hunt then
pistols continue to dance around Shelby
carrying
timing again the Ukrainian superstar has
proven that he was the real deal no
imitations accepted that is until people
began to call a certain 14 year old the
next simple anyway
so where exactly did this melon popping
wonderkin come from Ilia modesty osipov
was born in the industrial town of
orajovo zievo near Moscow Russia on May
1st 2005. his older brother first
introduced him to gaming when modesty
was around five or six years old and CS
1.6 really struck a chord
um
then shortly after monastery's seventh
birthday in 20 12 Global Offensive came
out and even though Monastery also spent
a lot of time playing games like Dota 2
CS go was the game that changed his
Destiny modesty was Global Elite by age
10. top level on face it by the time he
was 12 and doing incredible things on
the server at 13.
by the time he turned 14 montesy had
about 3 800 face at ELO to his name he
spent his free time playing in amateur
events and slowly built a reputation as
one of the most fearsome young players
the game has ever had despite his
obvious talent because he wasn't 16 yet
modesty couldn't exactly Go Pro quite
yet but he was offered the next best
thing legendary Ukrainian org Navi home
to the goat himself simple offered
modesty a spot in their newly
established Academy roster Navi Jr and
he was off to a great start
and connector
look at this do you have eyes
this is unbelievable this kid's like 10
years old man this is crazy
16 years old
and uh people are like oh these teams
are dog it's like dude
he went 30 and 5 man what set modesty
apart from the rest of the roster was
the fact that he didn't come from navi's
Esports Prospect boot camp instead he
got a direct invite from the coach and
he was younger than basically everyone
else
is
still no matter what the haters said
modesty was determined to make the most
of the opportunity modesty is still on
the a side he's gonna deal with him
first and foremost and that's not going
to be easy pick dead out rap ah modesty
gets the kill
and now a two on one really a one-on-one
the modesty is up for the job
what not even dying this guy is look at
this that shot
incredulous right
sheesh that is already crazy enough and
then he keeps repeating into every one
of these fights like look at this 4K
that is Phil there's gonna be the beat
coming forward however MDS finds a
crucial kill
and another one for monetizi and he gets
the triple
guitar
um
and of course there were the inevitable
comparisons to the other blonde Slavic
Phenom I think he's the next simple I'm
pretty sure
so his reaction speed mixed with his
work ethic mixed with his genetics mixed
with his beautiful little haircut
everything about him is just a little
Legend in him and he's 16 and he
literally just puts it on people's head
tops and servers but it's so crazy but
as it turns out modesty wasn't going to
Simply follow in the goat's footsteps
Navi already had their dream line up in
place on the main roster which meant
that modesty didn't really have a chance
to move up the ranks in Navi because
of potential so this a lot of energy and
if we will not freeze this energy it
will ruin himself inside so it's not
even healthy for us to have such better
so we needed to use it to add him if we
would add him if we would be able to
have like six-man roster
but we can't and so
we need to let him play
at least on territory level but now
he'll play in an entire one level and so
modesty chose to prove himself elsewhere
specifically on one of the biggest orgs
in Esports I think he's a very mature
player for his age and I think if G2
were to bring in modesty that lineup
could be absolutely insane right he's 16
years of age you give him half a year to
a year and I think this guy would be the
future of counters right this guy will
be a guy that could potentially take you
to to the next level once the G2 signing
officially went through in January 2022
modesty was ready to Take On The World
of Tier 1 Counter-Strike as an opera for
his new team
Odyssey on catwalk finds the timing
eight seconds drop the bomb it'd be
everything but it travels into the site
one on two for Odyssey now it's
sacrificial away
[Applause]
can you see right under I'm not even
sure but he gets the kill on Jax
regardless and this is looking like a
great defense want to see Alone Again
One versus four
oh good bit out of the shot but there's
one on catwalk oh that's quick oh that's
quick another one baited out perhaps but
robs is moving up modesty's aware 17
seconds it's absolutely no way oh he's
back in the middle no it can't happen
surely not 10 seconds he's backing off
rops can he catch him there's a little
peek a little shoulder showing he's back
at the bomb site the very least he's
gonna get the bomb plant here Rob's now
out in the open he's in a dangerous
position a little bit of a random
Molotov misses the shot at night
time to survive and get to that Antwerp
major oh but it's modesty new piece for
hooksie to work with with the double
Taps and make that three and you know
we're we're kind of destined for the
pistol Ace because modesty keeps this
clean
he called Big a bunch of onlineers well
the kid plays Lan goes for the clock
shots and finds the pistol Ace
despite monastery's individual
Excellence G2 as a whole were going
through a transitional period with three
new additions flanking Nico and Hunter
and the team didn't gel right away it's
all I want to see 10 seconds left this
can't be one he's still got time for
Acadian will take him down and it's
heroic making the Royal Arena to battle
liquid I do want to say you know if you
want to conclude the tournament for G2
we've seen this before man we've seen
them get into these Close Quarter
scenarios before where they lag a little
bit where they lose clutches that we
normally see them when we even saw a
couple of miscommunications happening as
well under G2 side that allowed for
Vitality to fight their way back into
the game so it's definitely something
they have to look at and I can't help
but feeling that we're seeing a G2
struggling mentally as well we've seen
some good things here but some of these
maps have been really really flat and I
think they're desperately in the need of
some sort of success some sort of
achievement some sort of of comforting
right and they haven't really found it
still even among his team's struggles
what was undeniable was modesty's
continued growth and development as a
player and he wasn't just putting up
numbers he was doing things no one has
ever seen before
he goes deep on the side actually again
probably should be dead already he's
gonna get the one kill there good little
double and might as well have been a
triple there and fantasy is in a lot of
trouble he no scopes one of them he
keeps going 10 seconds he fakes the pawn
spins around takes down Woody and now he
said the Hut running up close and
personal
flick he doesn't have the time surely
he doesn't have to move so much now
there is a Molotov on Turtle he's gonna
throw it he's not deep enough money she
still could have the shot oh and there
it is one of the best clutches we've
seen in a long long time that is
something special look I'll show you a
good strategy too from this bench
then you're coming here for example
for example boats are staying like this
okay
like this and this right if you aim here
Nate like this
what modesty did with cs go utility was
revolutionary While most of the old
Garden mainly concentrated on mechanics
aim and movement modesty spent every day
in the server coming up with new
ingenious ways to outplay everyone else
he was pushing the game past a Breaking
Point no one even knew existed
Counter-Strike was five years older than
modesty but CS go was still completely
and utterly bending to his will nicely
Don Dupree gets two players off of us
eight seconds left Point Blank off bite
we're on yes we are a little bit of
clutch sprinkled in for an attempt at
g2's first round to win no Apex tries to
jump across lethal mistake you do not
survive a clash versus the kid and now
modesty gets into the pit it's him
versus Spinx
a kit on the CT side but uh
on monessey like thunder but what both
modesty and G2 needed to legitimize
their new roster was a big win of course
the ultimate big one would be a major
something that eluded monastery's
teammate Nico for years despite his
undeniable Mastery of the game but
luckily there was another way I am
katavitsa one of csgo's most established
iconic tournaments G2 came in second at
the previous year's tournament the very
first one for monacy and we're now
looking to redeem themselves and it just
so happened that they hit a bit of a hot
streak winning two blast Premier Events
in a row leading up to the 2023 event
they came and they saw and they most
certainly conquered despite it being
over 1 000 days no less from G2 winning
a single map in a grand final series
obviously the conditions that you guys
were in extremely tough extremely
difficult we understand that but this is
the moment that you show to the world
your best face we hadn't seen this G2
yet we strugged a lot and we tried to
like look more or on our like
individually
the games you know and yeah now we are
more as a team we were looking at G2
live
too long here in there but it's now
three it
is the groups all the lights are green
if you're a G2 fanat man they're gonna
be rolling 9am once G2 got to caravitza
they were ready to make that a hat trick
that's something amazing
it gave me a lot of confidence it gave
me how was the fire oh yeah
amazing guys a little place Nico gone
early and has to smoke down which is
disrespected immediately Honestly though
the flash will repel the Invaders back
into the smoke and loads two on the
jewel barrettas nice back from bit go
either way as they charge is racing the
bomb carrier just right around the
corner he hasn't gotten to safety he's
gonna go down unless he can fight his
way out good luck have fun Perfecto gone
times a problem here 11 seconds bit with
no chance
will take another four G two are in
the bomb's not though
I'm not CT smoke hard glare and a good
shot to npl he's got him in
and now the two of them jks and modesty
gonna try and take the whole round take
every frag finish this map he's creative
oh not far off just spotted the back
where's the hell electronic gets the
dragon modesty oh how is he alive he
just bounces oh that's a way to finish
Stadium oh he needs honesty heating up
now you can't get away from modesty into
the sight and looking to say good night
is testless alone on the cycle he really
get him all
Mrs lightning seven bullets and a dream
of G2
look to make their dreams a reality
[Music]
[Applause]
unbelievable beautiful blend of Talent
on that side of the server you can see
it in their face it must feel so good
to break the curse
and to do it with a prodigy like modesty
alongside for the ride
your kind of Visa champions of 20 23.
Intel extreme Masters baby it's G2
thank you
a win at katowicea meant everything for
monacy sure it wasn't a major but it
changed him from a prodigy with immense
potential into a proven world-class
competitor at just 17 years old
montessor sent home contenders with
years of big Lan experience including
simple himself I don't want to say
anything I think I lost my voice
following their big win G2 then hit a
bit of a slump including taking an
abysmal 14th spot at the Paris major the
last one ever for CS go as the kid
Prodigy whose dreams will be crushed
alongside the Kovach and all of a sudden
he peeks he goes down the guillotine in
Peggy drops on the head of the king who
will never touch the ground down goes T2
and forward go fanatic but the team
seems to have no plans to mess with
their lineup and even amongst all the
disappointments modesty's performance
has remained consistently impressive
that's not even a no-scope
because every Peak just perfect and also
just reading where every fight is going
to be coming from
sometimes with modesty you're getting
these really crazy flicks of why they
call them the flash modesty even reached
the absolute top of the face at
leaderboards with 7 200 ELO at the time
of this video's publication the young
Opera left CS go Giants like simple and
xywoo in the dust
yeah yeah so if there was anyone who
thought that g2's winning potential was
spent at katowitza they had another
thing coming the team's results might
have slipped somewhat but the last IEM
cologne devoted to CS go was about to
prove all the haters wrong but a 2 vs 4
G2 unlikely to Fumble
with Nico dead they know where he is
hiding out on the tetris block swing
drip Checker yes that as well
hold on hold on Odyssey trying to save
them they need to be on that bomb soon
[Applause]
oh okay we're off to the third
dead by rounds will not last long back
to pistols back to Pace into B and in
your face honesty three digs in three
shots and he wants every single one will
he let jks get away to Donut the peak is
coming in a second The Flash is great
excellent on the Galaxy 1v1 his shot
landed and Rob's taken down Rain's Gonna
she's gonna get on that bomb with a
volley in front of him but he's already
defusing the shots right there modesty
is surely in surely D and D the last of
all is G2 manifest greatness
can you believe it any comments any
comments I don't know Phil thank you
it's a good trophy the good one so thank
you if katowice approved that modesty
could hang with the big boys cologne
truly cemented the fact that modesty was
here to stay with CS2 on the horizon he
truly represents a new generation of
Counter-Strike players ones that don't
need to follow in anyone's footsteps
even if things don't end up working out
on G2 in the long run or he simply
decides to make a change modesty has
plenty of other avenues available for
the future of his career yeah in my
career like I wanted to play for Navi
like because I just I love the
organization yeah like I don't know
maybe in the future I'm not sure let's
see in considering modesty's still just
18 years old the sky's the limit it's so
in saying to see a guy like in his age
especially being you know playing it is
like this
oh wait a second and he knows name is
here actually
now you just got to deal with kicker
imagine folks he gets this kill on apex
oh my God there's Tom have a ramp they
can hold it kicker catches at least
hooksy modesty looking for the third
time on his side oh my God he got it
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock